Una receta para
galletas de avena contiene
2 tazas de harina
por cada 3 tazas de avena.
¿Cuánta harina se necesita para elaborar
una gran cantidad de galletas que requieren
9 tazas de avena?
Veamos que nos dan.
Nos dan 2 tazas de harina,
nos dan entonces 2...
tazas
de harina....
2 tazas de harina,
por cada 3 tazas de avena,
2 tazas de harina
por cada
3 tazas
de avena,
esa es la receta.
Y lo que nos preguntan es,
¿Cuánta harina se necesita
para elaborar una gran cantidad
de galletas que requieren
9 tazas de avena?
Así es que ahora
tenemos una situación
en la cual se requieren
9 tazas de avena...
déjame ponerlo aquí...
tazas
de avena...
9 tazas de avena...
y te quiero mostrar
distintas maneras de hacer esto
para que elijas
la que más se te acomode.
Una manera de razonar
esto es, bueno,
sabemos que por
cada 3 tazas de avena
usamos 2 tazas
de harina,
ahora que vamos a usar
9 tazas de avena,
¿cuántas tazas de harina requerimos?
Eso es lo que nos están pidiendo,
si vamos de 3 tazas de avena
a 9 tazas de avena,
¿cuánta avena más estamos usando?
Bueno, estamos usando tres veces
la cantidad original de avena,
estamos multiplicando por 3,
al multiplicar por 3
las 3 tazas de avena,
obtenemos
9 tazas de avena,
si queremos usar la harina
en la misma proporción
tenemos que usar tres veces
la cantidad original de harina.
Entonces multiplicamos por 3
estas 2 tazas de harina,
por lo cual
requerimos usar
3 por 2,
tazas...
6 tazas de...
olvídate de este signo...
6 tazas de harina,
esa es la respuesta.
Esa es la cantidad de harina que se necesita
para elaborar una gran cantidad de galletas
que requieren
9 tazas de avena.
Otra manera de encontrar la solución
es estableciendo la proporción.
Si sabemos que
por cada
2 tazas...
por cada dos tazas de harina,
se requieren...
3 tazas...
se requieren 3 tazas
de avena,
entonces,
¿cuál es la cantidad
de tazas de harina?
Es una incógnita,
vamos a ponerlo con una variable "x"
o no, pongámoslo como un
signo de interrogación dentro de un cuadrito,
para que así
te quede más claro de qué se trata
todo este proceso.
Entonces,
¿cuál es esa cantidad
de tazas
de harina
que se requieren
para combinarse
con 9
tazas
de avena?
Yo prefiero el primer método
que hicimos,
pues es simple sentido común,
si triplicamos
la cantidad de avena,
tenemos que triplicar
la cantidad de harina,
para mantener
la proporción de la receta,
por el otro método
establecimos esta ecuación
que hay que
resolver usando álgebra,
algunos le llaman
multiplicación cruzada,
pero esa multiplicación cruzada
está basada en el álgebra.
Y te lo voy a mostrar.
En la multiplicación cruzada
se hace lo que se llama
una multiplicación en diagonal,
en este caso estaríamos multiplicando
2 por 9...
2 por 9
que es igual
al producto
de este
signo de interrogación por 3...
el producto de este signo
de interrogación,
lo que sea que represente,
en este caso las tazas de harina, por 3.
2 por 9 es igual a ? por 3,
2 por 9 = 18
que es igual a esa incógnita,
a ese signo de interrogación
en un cuadrito por 3,
así que el número de tazas
que se requieren por 3
es igual a 18,
mentalmente podemos calcular
que el número que se multiplica por 3 para dar 18
es 6
ó podemos dividir ambos lados
de la ecuación entre 3, para obtener 6.
Llegamos entonces al que el signo
de interrogación en un cuadrito
es igual a 6 tazas de harina,
la misma respuesta que obtuvimos
a través del sentido común.
Ahora, tú podrías decir,
esa multiplicación cruzada que hicimos
no tiene ningún sentido intuitivo,
¿qué es lo que hace válido igualar
esos productos cruzados?
¿por qué es válido multiplicar el denominador
de un lado por el numerador del otro lado
y eso que sea igual al numerador de un lado
por el denominador del otro lado?
Eso sale directamente del álgebra
y para ver eso
voy a sustituir esta incógnita por "x".
Tenemos
sobre 3
es igual y en vez de ese
signo de interrogación voy a escribir, "x"
sobre 9.
Algebraicamente estamos estableciendo que
esta cantidad de aquí
es igual a esta otra
cantidad de aquí,
un principio básico del álgebra
es que si hacemos algo
del lado izquierdo de una ecuación,
para mantener la igualdad,
tenemos que hacer lo mismo del lado derecho.
En este caso lo que queremos hacer es simplificar
esto para dejar del lado derecho tan solo la "x".
¿Y qué necesitamos hacer para que este
"x" sobre 9 se transforme en "x"?
Al estar la "x"
dividida entre 9,
si multiplicamos
por 9 los 9 se van a cancelar
y habremos despejado la "x".
Como dijimos, también necesitamos
multiplicar por 9 el lado izquierdo,
si estos dos términos eran iguales
antes de multiplicarse por 9
para mantener la igualdad,
hay que multiplicar
por 9 ambos lados de la ecuación.
Del lado derecho,
estos 9 se cancelan
y nos queda tan solo la "x",
mientras que del lado izquierdo
tenemos, 9 por 2/3,
esto es como
9 sobre 1 por 2/3,
esto es igual a 18/3
y por supuesto,
ya sabemos que 18/3 es igual a 6.
Todos estos métodos son válidos,
este desarrollo algebraico
que hice aquí lo hice para que
te dieras cuenta que es válida
la multiplicación cruzada que usamos,
sin embargo para un problema
tan simple como este,
tan solo necesitas sentido común.
Si estás aumentando
las tazas de avena por un factor de 3,
entonces aumenta las tazas de harina
por un factor de 3.